Speaker 1: We are starting today with the United
States Senate. We still don't know who controls
it. We still don't know who will control it. But
there is going to be a runoff in the state of
Georgia on December 6th between Raphael Warnock
and challenger Herschel Walker. This may be the
race that decides who controls the Senate. Let's
set it up and tell you where we are right now. At
this point in time, based on the seats that have
been determined definitively, it is Democrats 48
and Republicans 49 in the Senate. Remember,
Democrats need only 50 for a majority because
Kamala Harris, the vice president, would be the
51st vote, a tiebreaker in the event of any 5050
deadlock. It is quite possible. It is possible
that Democrats won't actually need Georgia. Why
do I say that? Well, in Arizona, Mark Kelly, the
incumbent Democrat, is five points ahead of Blake
Masters, the horrible Republican challenger with
76% of the vote in. Is it possible Masters could
still win? There it is. Is it likely? No. This
race, when it is hopefully called for Mark Kelly,
will put Democrats at 49. You then have the state
of Nevada in Nevada. The incumbent, Cortez Masto,
is running 1.8 points behind Adam Laxalt. But
experts who are looking county by county, what is
outstanding in Nevada say this may end up being a
defeat for Adam Laxalt, because even though 84% of
the vote is counted, the 16% that is left favors
Cortez Masto. The question is, will it favor her
enough for her to make up 1.8 points? We don't
know the answer. If indeed, Cortez Masto pulls
this out. That's 50 and the Georgia race becomes
451, which would make Kamala Harris's tie breaking
vote unnecessary. But we can't count on that. It
is totally plausible that control of the Senate
will depend on a December six runoff in Georgia.
Why is there a runoff if you look at the results?
Raphael Warnock won. Well, Georgia has what's
called the 50% threshold rule. If no candidate
gets to 50%, a runoff will be held between the
top two candidates. And indeed, because there
is a third party candidate in Georgia, Oliver,
who got a hair over 2% of the vote, although
Raphael Warnock won by 1.3 points, nearly 50,000
votes, there will be a runoff. This is the race
in which we must now get involved. I don't know
that I can make it down to Georgia in the next
few weeks, but we are going to try to see what
we can do at a distance. Can we do live streams
fundraising for Raphael Warnock and maybe get
matching funds set up? Well, we'll take a look.
Can we do some kind of live group mass phone
banking or at least get people signed up to
phone bank or something like that? We're going
to see what can we do? This is a race of critical
importance. There is a dramatic difference
between Democrats losing the House and Senate.
Versus Democrats keeping the Senate, but losing
the House? Yes. If Democrats lose the House,
they'll probably try to file articles of
impeachment against Joe Biden. They'll
obstruct. They'll do a whole bunch of stuff. But
in particular, when it comes to federal judges,
potentially a Supreme Court justice over the
next two years, we don't know. Control of the
Senate is absolutely critical. So if you live in
Georgia. Make sure that you're going to vote in
this one. Your vote, quite literally, could decide
who controls the Senate for the next two years and
who controls the Senate at the time of the 2024
election could also impact that presidential race.
So we're going to have much more about this,
but that is where we are. Herschel Walker,
right up there as one of the worst candidates I've
ever seen, can barely speak, can barely explain
his position on any issue. A complete and total
hypocrite says he's against abortion in all cases.
Urged and paid for multiple women to have
abortions. Says we need you know, we need we need.
Fathers involved in their kids lives. Is an absent
father himself pulled out a fake badge during a
debate, has no qualifications whatsoever and has
no business whatsoever being in the Senate. This
is not only about control of the Senate to some
degree. This is also about reducing the level of
humiliation of the United States globally. I get
emails from people all over the world Germany,
UK, Ireland, Australia saying, David, what is
wrong with the United States? A guy like Walker
should be laughed off any of these stages and
no other country would even stand a chance. And
I think generally speaking, those people are
right. Let's now talk about Lauren Boebert.